Here is an incredible thought.
You are the living ancestor of an unbroken
chain of lives stretching from you, through
your mother and your grandmother all the way
back through the complete history of life
on planet Earth to the very first life forms
that appeared around four billion years ago.
Isn’t that mind blowing!
And the fact that you exist proves that this
is true.
Combined, of course, with our understanding
of evolutionary history where life on Earth
has evolved into more complex forms over time
due to different pressures from the environment
and competition with other animals.
Try and imagine all of your direct ancestors,
all of those individual creatures that managed
to survive birth, avoided being eaten or dying
from disease and getting enough food for long
enough so that they could rear their young,
over and over and over again until it all
ended up with you.
Every single life form in that chain managed
to do that.
Now I’ve oversimplified a little bit by
just talking about a chain of life, in reality
there is a big web of lives going back into
the past, but just to keep things simple you
can think about a chain of all of your ancestral
mums.
Imagine your mum, and then her mum and her
mum and so on and so on going back through
all of human civilisation back to when we
were human hunter gatherers in Africa.
Direct ancestors of yours survived a super-volcano
that dimmed the Sun for 6 whole years, and
glacial periods where the Earth turned cold
and dry, and the total global population of
humans is estimated to have been about 10,000
people and may have been even lower.
Then back through the ages when our ancestors
were hunted by sabre toothed cats in the Savannahs
of Africa and lived in a world shared with
giant gorilla horses and giant sloths the
size of elephants.
Then through our common ancestors with the
great apes, monkeys through to the animals
that survived the impact of the meteorite
that killed off most of the dinosaurs.
The last common ancestor of humans and mice
was 100 million years ago, and all of the
mammals including you came from the first
mammals which were small shrew like animals.
Then back through earlier animals to the common
ancestor with dinosaurs and modern reptiles
and birds.
You are related to the first reptiles which
evolved from amphibians which evolved from
fish and they came from even earlier vertebrates.
And these came from the first animals to have
a heart and circulatory system, and then worms
with the first bilateral symmetry, the first
animals with nerves and muscles, to sponge
like creatures with the first different kinds
of tissues.
And before multicellular organisms there were
just single cells, complex cells, oxygen breathing
cells, first cells like bacteria, back to
the very first lifeforms that turned from
mixtures of chemicals to self replicating
molecules.
You come from an unbroken chain of lives that
span that unimaginable time, you are connected
to eons and eons of creatures all fighting
for survival and winning.
And I think that is so incredible, it completely
blows my mind.
Conclusion
What can you conclude from this thought?
Well what I take from it is that this chain
of life doesn’t just apply to us, is true
for every life from on the planet.
The Earth is like a living museum of all of
the life we know about so far in the entire
Universe.
So I think it is important that we preserve
as much of this biodiversity as possible.
Thats what I think but perhaps you have a
different take, I’d be interested to hear
you perspectives.
And, as always, posers are available, check
the link in the description below.